I'm mark Dwight the founder of rickshaw
bag works in San Francisco rickshaw bag
Works is a manufacturer of custom
messenger bags backpacks tote bags and
assorted accessories we're getting back
to the old fashioned way of making
things here at rickshaw
we have 22 employees we have 12 people
in our factory doing cutting so our
sewing staff is a skilled craft
workforce and so everyone here is an
expert sower they either come here as an
expert sewer or learned on the job we
forget we used to have a vibrant cut and
sew industry here in San Francisco we're
the birthplace of Levi's Levi's used to
manufacture here for our first two sours
we ran an ad in the local Chinese
newspaper called the Tsingtao day light
the day that we had our interviews 450
people showed up at our door it was
madness that day we selected two sewers
but from that mass of people that showed
up and ever since then we've never run
another ad we simply ask our team does
anyone know anybody who wants to sew
I believe there's a renaissance in micro
manufacturing here in the United States
and I actually think that's where the
next wave of manufacturers will come
from is small factories I think we have
to preserve the big ones that we already
have but I don't think we're going to be
seeing big factories start up like they
did in the old days I think the new age
is small nimble manufacturers doing
custom work and using today's advanced
tools with a skilled operator is I think
the future of manufacturing in the US I
have nothing against the global
outsourcing movement there are obviously
lots of issues around you know social
justice and environmental issues those
are major issues but I'm not doing what
I do to protest that I'm doing this as a
celebration of the fact that I like to
make what I sell and that I like to work
with a team of people that are
craftspeople and designers who want to
make products like this right here where
we go to work San Francisco has a very
strong cycling culture and you know this
whole movement of fixed gear and single
speed cycling and now kind of more
broadly the urban cycles we're a part of
that community and rickshaw itself means
human powered vehicle and we thought the
name was apropos for a company that kind
of lives at the intersection of bags and
bikes
there are these things that are almost
quintessentially of the place and
whether it's Chianti wine or champagne
in Champagne region or messenger bags in
San Francisco there's this notion of
where the stuff comes from and who makes
it you know we're all live in San
Francisco we live and breathe the San
Francisco culture every day
and somehow that translates into the
products that we make and I think people
are interested in that and they want to
know the maker a fascinating thing about
where we are here at rickshaw is in this
neighborhood called Dogpatch this is the
old shipbuilding neighborhood a matter
of fact at the end of the street here is
the old pier 70 shipbuilding complex
this neighborhood has become the
epicenter of the maker movement in San
Francisco and there are chocolate makers
bread makers beer makers bag makers all
kinds of maker activity going on in this
neighborhood in the old industrial
spaces that have been converted into
smaller industrial warehouse spaces you
know a lot of people talk about
entrepreneurial studies and how schools
are now developing entrepreneur programs
but I think people tend to think of that
as the entrepreneur who's going to go
start a high-tech company that's going
to last off quickly and get acquired and
I'm here to tell you that there's a
whole different side to being an
entrepreneur which is just being a small
business person I'm not thinking about
selling that business I'm not thinking
about growing it in the hockey-stick
fashion I'm thinking about one thing and
that's making it profitable how big it
is how successful it is is really
inconsequential when it comes to just
running day-to-day business and trying
to achieve profitability and maintain
profitability
it always takes more time money and
effort than you expect I will also tell
you that your business will look
different three years from now if you do
start a business than you think it does
on paper when you start it it just
happens that way the great thing about
starting a business is you get out there
you try your first ideas you get them on
the market and the market tells you
exactly what they think of what you're
doing once you have a product and you've
kind of convinced yourself that there's
a market for it and people want to buy
it really the challenge is getting it
out there getting your name out there at
rikshaw our only challenge is that not
enough people know we exist we're still
a tiny little company and we hear all
the time wow I never even heard of you
guys and that's really our biggest
challenge we open our factory up every
day to let people come in and see what
we do people ask me all the time hey can
I take pictures take a video - go for it
put it on Facebook put it on Twitter we
want people to see that we're actually
making things here anyone can take apart
my product and have a pattern and remake
it but you know what doing it every day
day in day out that's the challenge you
know really takes wanting to really get
passionate about it and we're very
passionate about what we do here so what
keeps it fun and exciting it's not for
everybody but it's what we like to do
here